(dramatic cinematic music)
- Happy 4th of July!
- So I have to say you've definitely
had some memorable moments in this season
and folks will find your
memorable moments this season,
but one through three,
what's been your favorite
moment of the franchise?
- We both said I think, it's something
that we can't necessarily
say about the current season.
- Yeah.
- [Joe] That's what we were
kind of talking about earlier.
- Okay.
- We got some,
we got to do something there.
- What episodes
of those can we be on the lookout for it?
- [Joe] It's like seven
and eight finale, I think?
- Yeah, the finale.
- Yeah.
- The finale?
- [Jacqueline] That's like your favorite
scene of the franchise?
- I think so, yeah.
- Okay.
- And filming it
never seemed to do.
- Yeah.
- Okay.
- I don't know like out of all the scenes,
that everyone has done it would
be the one that I would say,
like there's so many scenes that I love.
- Yeah.
- From other character's storylines,
- But that was my favorite one to do.
- For sure, yeah.
- [Jacqueline] What was your
favorite one of somebody else's
that you got to watch?
- From this season or from any season?
- [Jacqueline] Well,
let's go to the first two,
so that way you don't give any spoilers.
- I love the prom so much.
- Yeah, that was incredible.
- That set was beautiful
and it was such a,
- Yeah.
- such a rewarding moment.
- I really just like the
opening scene of the boys
playing Dungeons and Dragons.
- Oh, yeah, it's so great.
- I think it's like maybe the
quickest way into a show ever,
I don't know, it's like you're instantly,
oh, I totally understand these characters,
their dynamic together
and it just immediately kind of sets that.
- Yeah.
- Let's talk about how
your character's changed
over the first three seasons,
like his evolution,
it's been pretty great.
- Sure, yeah.
- It's amazing.
- It goes from you know, kind
of being a selfish narcissist,
kind of asshole character
to slowly growing up
and discovering what it means
to put other people before yourself
and I think that this season
kind of picks up where that has left off
and kind of more questions
about just your life,
what do you wanna do, what do you wanna be
and how do you kind of get there,
you start to kind of pile in.
- And then also for you,
since it's been season one,
you've seen these kids
get like complete grown ups almost now.
- It's like, upsetting.
- Yeah,
so what's it like watching
them basically grow up
in front of you with the five?
- It's like they're my
cousins or something,
it's like they're my little cousins
that I get to see like,
oh, we're gonna hang out,
we get to hang out again
every once in a while.
But they're great, they're
just like really solid people,
especially under the circumstance
of having so many people
just interested in them and who they are.
Yeah, I just love the
kids, they're amazing.
- Yeah, they're really impressive.
- [Jacqueline] Are they asking you guys
for any advice, like
hey, words of wisdom, no?
- Hell, no.
- Every once in a while, but you know.
- They know way more.
- They know way more?
- Yeah.
- Both of you guys have
been acting for a while,
did you guys have like first summer jobs,
did you have like your McDonald's gig?
- I worked in a bookstore.
- Ah!
What was your first summer job?
- I was a pizza delivery guy,
I was like a bus boy for a long time
I had a lot of restaurant jobs.
- Did you get fired?
- And babysitting.
- Babysitting?
- Didn't get fired, no,
I did actually babysit my
sisters occasionally, yeah.
- That's not as bad as babysitting.
- Life preparation.
- Doesn't count.
- Using your sisters.
- No, doesn't count.
- It's like being a person.
- Built in, yeah.
- And then what's your
favorite 4th of July activity,
what do you like to do on the 4th?
- I like being with my
family, going to Cape Cod,
that's kind of a tradition in our family,
so I like doing that.
- Fireworks.
- Yeah, definitely.
- I feel you on that.
- I hate my family.
(laughing)
- Afternoon, ladies.
- [Both] Afternoon, Billy.
- Dig the new suit, Mrs. Wheeler.
- Thank you.
(mellow upbeat music)
- You came in in season two
and gave me a moment that
I sort of loved, but hated,
because you were so mean,
like when you got there,
but when you like made your entrance,
I was like that's a great TV moment,
it's one of my favorites.
- I was very lucky
that I had that entrance for sure.
- [Jacqueline] (laughing) But what's one
of your favorite moments
from the franchise?
- I don't know, it's so
hard to pick it apart,
I mean, it's so beloved
I think in many ways,
but I think for me obviously
the opening credits
were a big thing the first time,
the night that it came out,
I watched the whole season
and I remember that dee, dee, dee, dee.
- Yeah.
- You know,
the letters coming up
in that bold, neon red
and just feeling like
this is something unique,
I think in a lot of ways
and I think that's reflective
of the actual show.
- So you only have season two to go by,
but what's different about your character
between last year and
this year, no spoilers?
- Totally, no spoilers,
I think what's different
is that we see a much
darker side of Billy,
that doesn't have this humanized quality
that we saw in season two
with the scene with his Dad,
those sort of things, until the end,
we have such a fantastic payoff
at the end of season three.
But I got to delve so deep
into making unusual choices,
that I think puts the audience on edge,
which was really exciting
and I was really lucky,
my story arc is so
fleshed out this season.
- Working with the kids?
- Yeah.
- 'Cause it was about a year
between season two and season three.
- They grew up a lot, yeah.
- What's it like
watching these kids grow up?
- I think Caleb's started to
get a little bit of bum fluff
going on around under
his nose and I love it,
I mean, we love sort of heckling over it.
But no, I just, I think the maturity
and the ability living in the public eye,
the complete loss of their anonymity,
I think the ability to still
remain humble and work hard,
I have a lot of admiration for that,
because at 13, 14, 15, 16,
you wouldn't have had me doing that,
so I think that's really,
I respect that definitely.
- Yeah, 13, 14, 15, 16 here
is when people get their first summer job.
- Yeah.
- [Jacqueline] What was
your first summer job?
- I worked in a butcher,
I scraped like the frozen
blood off the floor,
then I worked in
McDonald's and I got fired
and then I was a dish pig and
a barrista for five years,
- Excellent.
- so I had
a interesting upbringing.
- Yeah.
- I never worked in retail,
which was a bit different to the butcher
looking back on it.
- [Jacqueline] What did you get fired for?
- I can't remember, it
was something super silly,
like I was working with my mates
and we were mucking around,
- Guys.
- something harmless.
- Well, here we have the 4th of July
as like our summer holiday,
- Yeah.
- and everyone barbecues
and there's fireworks.
- [Dacre] Yeah.
- [Jacqueline] So I don't
know what the Australian is.
- Australia Day.
- It is?
- Yeah.
- But what is your favorite
activity on that day?
- Well, in Australia we get super wasted
and we listen to this thing
called Triple J's Hottest 100,
which is where over the course of the day
up until the fireworks in the evening,
they count down the hottest 100 songs,
that the country has
voted over the last year
and they're not just pop songs,
they're super alternative,
like the station is the
alternative station, so everything
and you count down and you drink
and you drink and you drink
and I'm not a big drinker,
so you'll probably get me in three p.m.,
but the fireworks and the number
one happens at like 10 p.m.
and that's kind of our big day.
- That's so cool.
- Yeah.
- [Jacqueline] I wanna go to Australia
to participate in this.
- Look, we wanna come here
and participate in the 4th of July,
so I get to do it fictitiously in the show
and I get to do it in real
life in a couple of days,
so it'll be good.
(dramatic upbeat music)
- [Jonathan] Together.
- Hi, guys.
- Hello.
- Hi.
- I'm so excited,
I'm ready to see this season
and I will say that you guys
gave me one of my favorite,
but also least favorite moments
is when you friend zoned him
in season one with that gift,
I'm not gonna lie, I was so upset.
But what was your favorite
moment from the franchise?
- Oh, hm.
- Just the first season.
- Yeah.
- So I always look back, so from this.
- A lot of new stuff.
- Yeah, those are,
I loved the whole end
and kind of fighting the demogorgon.
- Yeah, the tree stuff.
- You know what I really liked,
I liked when it was cold,
it was really cold that morning,
but that morning we shot the gun scene.
- That was a great, yeah.
- I don't know why,
just those early scenes,
it all feels so new.
- Some days just like,
scenes that don't seem
much, but just in your mind
you're like, oh, that was a
good day, that was a fun day.
- Yeah, I really liked that day.
- Yeah.
- That means you guys
are having too much fun.
- Oh, my favorite moment
I think is when we're
in the woods actually,
I forgot about that.
- Yeah, a lot of the stuff
in the woods is really cool,
especially night stuff in the woods,
'cause it gets really, really dark
and it's I don't know, I can feel it.
- You're in it, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- So how do you think your character,
I mean, no spoilers, has changed?
I mean, this is now three seasons in,
the kids are getting older,
you guys have had a whole transformation,
very happy about that by the way.
- Yeah, I think they've just matured,
you know, all the characters,
going through what they've
been through together,
- Yeah.
- in the first two seasons
and trying to get on with
some normal normality
and trying to push through, it's hard.
But this season they're
turning into young adults.
- Yeah.
- Just growing up.
- It must be interesting for you guys too,
'cause you're literally
watching them go from children
to young adults.
- They're kids.
- Yes.
- So how has it been
working with them through that transition?
- It's good.
- Yeah, it is.
- They're such good kids and
every year they come back
and we have, the show's blown
up, so have their careers,
but they're really good at just kind of--
- They're still young,
like it still gets really silly,
when everybody's in the
same scene together.
- It's a little family.
- Yeah, it's really nice.
- Awesome, so this is all 4th of July,
so what is your favorite,
I know you're British,
4th of July holiday.
- I'll skip this question.
- Maybe what's your
favorite barbecue holiday
or summer activity, but
here at the 4th, you know,
people do fireworks, they
do all kinds of stuff,
so do you have one?
- We don't do 4th of July,
I like Christmas a lot,
it's my favorite time of year.
- [Jacqueline] Okay, any 4th of July
sort of days that you like?
- Yeah, I mean, you
know, I think it's about
just being around people
you wanna be around,
having a cook out, maybe some fireworks.
- We had a good 4th of July this year.
- Yeah.
- We had a pool.
- Oh, yeah, God, you just hang,
just a good hang day, right.
- I like that.
- Yeah.
- We did a talent show.
- Ah, I wanna be in it.
Alright, thank you, guys.
- Holy Mother of God.
(dramatic cinematic music)
(roaring)
(upbeat electronic music)
(melodic upbeat music)